So there was this guy named Hu,
and he created a set of moments.
And what was really cool about
the moments that he created,
is that they were rotation,
translation, and scale invariant.
And you'll see I, I put scale in green
here, because for what we're about to do
the translation part is taking
account by just using central moments.
We don't really need rotation and
variant that much,
because people don't tend to do
their aerobics at 45 degree angle.
But we do get scale differences, right?
If things are closer to the image,
or, or closer to camera or
farther from the camera,
things get bigger or smaller.
So we want to create some
descriptors that are invariant, and
Hu moments are, are of that type.
And we're going to use 7 of them, and
that's what these 7 Hu moments are.
And I'm going to show you
the equations for them.
You would never write these down.
You would go get an implementation
of them because otherwise,
you'll make a mistake et cetera.
But, but here they are, okay?
And in fact, they're so ugly that
they don't even all fit on one page,
so you see it says this is h1,
and that's mu20,
remember mu are the central moments,
okay, plus mu02.
And then they continue, h6,
and then h7 is even more ugly.
There they are, they're just that
sort of that complicated ugly thing.
All you need to know is we now have
a translation, and rotation, and
scale invariant system.
So the details of what the,
the features do are not that important
except that they behave the way we want
them to behave under particular
types of transformations.
What matters is, I'm going to compute
these features on both the MEI and
MHI, so the binary version and
the grayscale version, and
that's going to give
me a feature vector.
And given a feature vector,
I can build classifiers.